وثائقي سريه اخرى تزيد اللقطه واشاره
الاستفهام حول الرئيس الامريكي جو بيدن
فبعد الاوراق الحساسه التي وجدت في مكتبه
والتي تعود لفتره شغله منصب نائب الرئيس
خمس صفحات اضافيه عثر عليها البيت الابيض
في منزل بيض فيولمنجتون في ولايه ديلر
لتتم احالتها لوزاره العدل السؤال الذي
تطرحه وزاره العدل الامريكيه ان كان بيضا
منتهيكا للقانون ام لا في الحالتين سيواجه
تحقيقات قضائيه بينما الرجل في ذروه شعبيه
بعد انجازاته في المنصب حتى الان
انا اخذ الوثائق السريه والمواد السريه
على محمل الجده نتعاونوا بالكامل مع وزاره
العدل
خاصه بعد التكتم على وجودها حتى انتهاء
انتخابات التجديد النصفي التي جرت في
نوفمبر الماضي وتثير تكهنات حول مستقبل
بيض السياسي بيض نفسه الذي انتقد عندما
مسئوليه الرئيس السابق
لدى كشف الوثائق السريه التي احتفظ بها في
منزله في فلوريدا
فرصه تفتح اوسع الابواب للجمهوريين لرمي
التهم على الرئيس الحالي واضعين الحالتين
في كفتين ميزان متوازيتين
ورغم ان بعيدا ابدى تعاونه في القضيه عكس
ترامب الا ان ذلك لن يبعده عن التحقيقات
والاسئله العديده خاصه بعد تاخير الكشف
ليس الجمهوريون وحدهم بل بعض من
الديمقراطيين انتقدوا التهمه التي قدمها
بيضا على طبق من ذهب للحزب المنافس الى
عمر العربيه